I made and marshmallow Ron Swanson oh
my gosh his arms are crossed because
he's mad at all the other marshmallow
workers for annoying him you like it
fine when I was trying to decide the
subpar toolbox only had one wrench so I
was lucky it was a three-quarters there
hadn't been screwed yeah man you are
lucky come on Ron what I need your help
by the time I was done this
hundred-year-old piece of American-made
cast iron was singing like a bird
now to most people this story would seem
boring that's ridiculous it's a story
about a radiator but to me it was
immensely satisfying because I enjoy
fixing radiators you like fixing this
town Leslie you always have
you know it's an uphill battle but you
love the struggle
I would also add that you've already
done a hell of a lot to make this town
better and people like this young man
here will benefit from your hard work he
is a beautiful boy he's quite a looker
thank you Ron
nothing
Clear My Throat
every year I give Leslie the same
present I give everyone a crisp 20 bill
and every year she gets me
something thoughtful and personal
it makes me Furious
this year she outdid herself
she had it installed over the weekend
so
so beautiful
why are you here
come back to work
nah
come back
I want you to come back well I don't
want to come back
the end
I was talking to Andy about you and he
made me realize that I need you back at
work what did he say don't recall fine
I'll come back
good
okay I'm leaving
bye Zuzu
bye Duke silver
my mom has all your albums
I recognize you the day we met
have you told anyone no
good girl
hello Diane I have brought you flowers
also chocolates
and some Grout cleaner I noticed you
needed Grout cleaner so I brought that
too
very romantic
my kids are non-negotiable Ron
the package deal I know I'm sorry Diane
I really am
I've been alone most of my Life by
choice
and kids
this is all new for me
but I'd like to become familiar with it
if you give me a chance to prove myself
I did bring the girl something
I thought I could teach them to
saw
and I realized that seems dangerous
it's November 8th yes well these girls
didn't get a chance to go
trick-or-treating so somewhere in this
house there's some candy why don't you
find it and we'll get right out of your
hair
hold on one second
you having fun ladies
yeah all right I got some uh calcium
chews and roll
of cookie dough okay what do you say
girls
tremendous
appreciate it
all my life I have avoided Europe and
it's multitudes of terribleness but it
turns out much to my surprise there is
actually one place in Europe that is
worth seeing
these tiny islands off the coast of
Scotland where God's chosen elixirs are
distilled barreled and prepared for
consumption
this is worth the trip
dear Ron you have now reached the
cliffsides overlooking the islands as
you sit here and gaze upon the waters
please read out loud the poem by the
great Scotsman Robert Burns love Leslie
oh were my love young lilac fair with
purple blossoms to the spring
and I a bird to shelter there when we
read on my little wing
how I would mourn when it was torn by
Autumn Wilde and winter rude
but I would sing on wanton wing when
youthful May its Bloom renewed
[Music]
I don't know what she thought I'd get
out of that
[Music]
breakfast nope
oh I don't know
come on
there has never been a sadness that
can't be cured by breakfast food
that's fair
someone else is going to have to drive
though my eyes are basically useless
right now Hey Ron
can I ask you a question
sure
it's about April
I don't like to get involved in people's
personal I hurt her feelings
and now she's pissed at me I feel like
if I could just explain myself she'd
understand but she's avoiding me
it's making me miserable
April's in the hospital sick with the
flu what
what I knew it
knew it I didn't know that is she okay
yeah she's fine you can go visit her
tomorrow morning but don't tell her I
told her I won't
no no no no no
no
this is the one this is oh why you have
so many keys we did surgery just like
you taught us okay you know what why are
you girls clean up all this hair and I'm
gonna talk to Ron
it's not I'm gonna take this bag too
you need to fix the
not that bad nobody got hurt it's
extremely bad I love this woman and I
just want to show her that I'm capable
of watching her children without
something horrible happening
what
did you just say you love Diane no I did
not yes you did that is so
nice for God's sake Hanson will you
please focus on the larger problem
girls girls I don't know what you think
you heard but please don't tell your
mother what you incorrectly think you
heard
I love nothing
Diane this is all my fault I let them go
into my nurses bag
well who has been having fun with
scissors
hey you're not mad that's fine they're
kids once Zoe put ivy in the dryer so
I'm still incredibly sorry I feel like I
let you down it is so sweet to me how
much you care
this is why I love you
oh
well
I love you too
how'd you remember
woof woof
Barb
why here
because this tree reminds me of you it
it's drawing and quiet
and always here when you need it
or whatever
I've always felt a certain kinship with
April and this is proof that I was
correct
not the nice things she said about me
the fact that I buried a large amount of
gold under that same tree years ago
I have since moved it
or have I
or was I lying the whole time
or was I lying about lying
or was there never any goal to begin
with
or Mouse rap CD 30 dollars
candy bars fifty dollars fifty dollars
God people here are so cheap April where
have you been over two phone calls came
in unimpeded we're raising money for my
college education Ron I took a second
job back in my old job
do you want a shoe shine it's a hundred
dollars laugh all you want Kyle I
already took the money out of your
wallet oh
good news Sean
you have just won a Ron Swanson
scholarship
I don't think so I don't remember
applying for anything wrong Swanson
scholarship
wait are you serious
stop this no
stop or you lose the money
I have enjoyed parts of our time
together
something